first time ever tried some cocaine was
over here in beautiful baton rouge
louisiana
i think um and i went for a run i
thought it was a
you know a performance enhancer i'd
heard that
and i guess at the time i was training
for a half marathon
and so i caught me a couple of grams of
um you know that white
donkey dust you know a little bit of
brain kick
and uh and i went for the longest run
i've ever
ever ran i ran for 11 miles um
because i never ended up doing the half
marathon because i got into cocaine
uh nothing will keep you out of a
marathon like a little bit of uh
you know that white you know a little
bit of saturn sugar you
know so i i remember just running along
the railroad tracks and i would stop and
do a couple bumps
and you know i did a couple grams and
ran 11 miles
and then i jumped in over a fence into
some people's backyard and they were
doing
marshmallows it was kind of a i don't
know if it was a
maybe a family event but they were older
this was the older people were still
awake drinking beer and doing
marshmallows on a fire and i hung out
with them
i didn't have a shirt on i was sweating
from the run and from the drugs
and i sat there and ate a good deal of
marshmallows high on cocaine and spent
some time with them
and they were lsu tigers fans lsu tigers
and so was i
so we had some common ground there hope
you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one